All right, thank you.
Right. Hello, everyone.
Uh, my name is Aish Shah.
I'm the product manager for network
and application services at AWS.
I focus on network firewall and threat intelligence.
And I'm joined by Sushmita. She
is the senior director of product at
Lumen, managing managed security services
for Lumen. And we are
extremely excited here to talk about
how Lehmen and AWS have been working
together for the last couple of months
to help you.
Elevate the security of your
cloud workloads.
All right. So,
before diving deep into the joint
solution,
uh, I just want to give you a brief
introduction of what AWS
Network firewall is.
So AWS Network Firewall is a
fully managed cloud firewall
service. This is AWS Native Firewall
Service
that allows you to deploy essential
network protections, so you can
inspect any traffic that is going in
and out of your VPCs
as well as apply filtering policies
between your VPCs to stop lateral movement
of traffic.
The service is fully managed, which means
you don't have to worry about deploying the firewall
infrastructure.
You don't have to worry about the maintenance upgrade
of the software. It's done automatically
for you and it horizontally scales automatically
up to 100 gigabits per second,
depending on your traffic volume.
We have a built-in stateful inspection engine
on the firewall which allows you to write
any specific rules that
are
required from your business application standpoint. So
you can write traffic matching rules based on
IPs,
fully qualified domain names, URL
filtering, um,
you can also do IDS IPS,
threat signature-based rules.
So it gives you lots of flexibility
on how you want to control traffic
that is leaving
out of your VPCs.
And it's fully managed by
firewall manager services so you can.
Apply consistent security policy
across your entire AWS organization and
different accounts using that single pane of glass.
So,
one of the things that I heard last year when
I was talking about network firewall with the customers
is
we want simplified security.
And, um,
especially like managing rules at scale
is a challenge for us.
What can you do to make it easy for us?
And for that,
I'm extremely excited to announce
um the partner manage rules
on AWS network firewall.
So earlier at Reinvent,
we launched Partner manage rules, which
gives you
curated list of threat intelligence
from some of the top AWS
marketplace partners
directly into the network firewall.
At launch,
we partnered with 7 vendors,
including Lumen,
to give you best of breed threat
intelligence that you can now
easily apply to your firewall policy
and protect your network
and improve your network security.
What it means is now you
get. Automatic
updates on this threats directly
into your firewall policy, which means you don't
have to worry about writing your own rules,
managing IP lists, domain lists,
or writing threat signatures.
It's all done by
Partners who have their entire
team of security experts
working on behalf of you and giving you
the best of breed threat intel
as well as
keeping you ahead
of attacks before they are even
discovered using their
threat intelligence.
It is fully integrated into the network
firewall console, which means
you don't have to worry about
going to the marketplace to subscribe to
those rules. You can do that directly from
the console,
and then you can with a few clicks
apply those rules directly into your firewall
policy. So it's all done within the
network firewall console,
which significantly simplifies the
operational complexity that was involved in
either writing the rule or managing these policies
at scale.
So as you can see here, when you log
into the console,
now you will see an option to add
partner manage rules.
When you click on that, you will see
a list of all available rule groups,
including the defender managed rule
groups from Lumen, which is available on
the console.
It will tell you exactly
what type of threats are being
covered from those rule groups. So
specifically talking about the defender
managed rule groups, you'll get.
Coverage from malware-based threats.
Command and control threats, bot activities,
etc. directly
over here. So with one click
check box,
you can now add those rule groups in your
network firewall policy.
And this threat intel is coming from Black Lotus
Labs, so they are using their global Blackbone
and, and giving you and keeping you ahead
of the attacks before, before, you
know, they are even discovered.
So
this is how we are making it super simple
for you,
so you can
get ahead of the attackers.
So here is an architecture diagram,
one of the common deployment types on how
customers deploy a network firewall
to build a centralized inspection
capability
using AWS network firewall. And
with this integration,
you can now protect all your
workloads within VPCs
using network firewall and
the threat intelligence which is powered by
Lumen. So, here is
how you can deploy
network firewall and inspection VPC and as
I showed, you can add Lumen Defender
Manage rule group on your network firewall
policy.
So with that, I will introduce Sushmita
and have her walk you through like
more details on, you know, like how this
all
will help you alleviate your network security.
Sushmita. Thank
you Amish. Um,
hello all. Thank you for joining this session. I'm
Sushmita Nayak and I had all of our
network security services and
threat intelligence products at Lumen.
Uh, before we talk about
what Lumen's outside in intelligence
means and how it powers
the firewall security,
I want to introduce a little bit about who is
Lumen
and, uh, what kind of security products
and solutions and what kind of threat intelligence we
bring. So Lumen for
those who may be less aware,
is really the
Internet service provider that
if you're a business of any size,
uh, whether you are a
local data center or you have an office
or a cloud data center,
if you need Internet connectivity, most likely
you are getting it from Lumen.
So we are one of the number
one
hash peer network
globally
and we bring the Internet to
all of your
um enterprises.
Also proud to uh share that we
provide the Internet connectivity for this conference
reinvent,
uh, it is powered by Lumen.
With that introduction, um, I wanted
to talk a little bit about what we mean
by,
um, cyber intelligence and why is it
important to have more cyber intelligence,
um, now than ever.
Really attacks are escalating, uh,
the risks are real and for
anyone of you who is deploying a
workload on AWS, which
probably is most of you.
You are worried about the attacks that are escalating
all of your workloads, whether it is on malware
or proxies or botnets or
phishing attacks or ransomware attacks
or DDoS attacks. All of them
have multiplicative
growth in the last several years,
and really what that means to each
of you
if you are on a security team
or you're on the network security team,
you are worried about whether
your cloud workloads are indeed
safe. Proud
to announce that we are
one of the launch partners
with AWS
to provide our
Lumen's threat intelligence
powered by Black Lotus Labs.
Black Lotus Labs for introduction
is Lumen's threat intelligence
arm. I'll introduce more
about who is Black Lotus Labs in a minute,
but we are bringing in the
proven Black Lotus Labs threat
intelligence.
That is unique to our
network at the visibility and the scale
of our our network and how it operates
for the first time we're bringing this
outside our network
to the ecosystem to AWS
network firewall customers.
Never before have we
brought this threat intelligence
to ecosystems like AWS,
so. What's in it for you
guys if you are a firewall customer
for the first time, as Amish was mentioning,
when you are managing your firewall
right within those console,
you can look up Lumen as a
partner manage rule and be able
to subscribe to it and immediately
deploy it into
one or more of your VPCs or firewalls
right away, getting protection from threat
intelligence in minutes.
So this is Lumen Defender
managed rules.
The net of it is that
it is a managed.
Rule set that is provided
by Lumen and AWS.
What that means is
it comes at no operational cost
to you. Lumen brings the rule
sets in Surikata form
to AWS, which is bringing in
those rule sets automatically
updated into your firewalls,
protecting your networks without you
having to worry about it, completely hassle-free.
OK, so talk about
why Lumen defender manage
rules. There's a lot of threat intelligence
out there, so the question is
yet another threat intelligence. So
do I need it? I think that's the real question.
There are 3
elements of what we bring to the table. One
is early threat infrastructure
detection.
Lumen, because it's an ISP,
because we have the most peered
network globally,
because we can see each of the traffic that
is crossing our network
because of our global status,
we can
uniquely identify good versus
bad traffic.
And we can see it when the traffic is
coming on a network
and we can immediately because
we can see it,
we can say if it's good or bad traffic
and we can stop it if it's bad traffic.
So again uniquely positioned
threat intelligence from a network perspective
by Lumen. Second,
rapid
automated protection. What does that mean?
As I mentioned earlier,
you don't have to do anything. Looming
behind the scenes together with AWS
network firewall infrastructure is automatically
updating those rules, and I'm
proud to share
that we update our rules daily.
Which is pretty unheard of if you are a
CISO or a security team or a
network security, uh, you know, uh, individual,
you'll say, well, I want if I know a
threat, I want to be able to protect from
it right away.
Most threat intelligence companies,
most firewall companies
protect on a
few days a week. They update their rules.
Lumen is probably one of the only vendors
who provides threat intelligence updates
daily.
Actionable intelligence with context. Let
me explain what that is and why is that important.
IPs, DNSs, URLs,
they're all kind of cold elements like
19.2.5.235.
Like what does that even mean to anyone?
What Lumen brings is actionable
context to that particular IP.
Explaining what is that IP,
which threat actors, which, which malware,
which category of of attack it belongs
to, is it malware or botnet or
C2 or proxy? What kind
of severity is it? What's the reputation of that
IP? And we constantly have
AI-led algorithms
along with human intelligence
rank and rate those IPs in terms of severity
so that you don't have to do that.
So automatically
classifying those IPs and
automatically providing context in
the first version of the release we have limited
context but we're working on providing enriched
context for example,
what does this IP,
uh, if it's a malware which threat actor, which
threat family is it associated with,
right? So you wanna know about that, you know,
which nation state. Actor has
been involved with launching an
attack from that IP
so we are one of the few vendors
who believe in providing
actionable context along with your
IPs so that when the IP gets
blocked on the firewall, it hits the logs
and your se ops teams are watching those logs.
They're like, what is this IP and why did
why anyone block it? We give you the context
so. Because
of these three reasons,
I think Lumen's threat intelligence is
sort of by far one of the top
ones.
Let's detail a little bit in the architecture
of how this works.
So behind the scenes, starting on the left.
You have Black Lotus Labs, which is us,
our threat intelligence, which is looking at the
global network,
looking at our AI-led, you know, algorithms
as well as human specialists and researchers
who are looking at the attacks and
curating the threat intelligence
that is then being. Generate are formed
into sort of sorryrikata rules and
reputation data that is being associated with
it and these rule sets are being
ingested in the form of Lumen Defender
manage rules that are being then pushed
into the AWS firewall if
you have subscribed to it
and this then then protects both
the inbound and outbound traffic
coming into your workloads or going out
from your workloads.
It's actually the amazing
thing is how AWS
AWS Network firewall has
brought the richness of this
experience to you guys. It's
not that you have to go into the marketplace
and search for threat intelligence and
learn about it and figure out what to do.
They have built it right into the
firewall administration page, the policy
page, where you can go look up.
Of vendors that bring the threat intelligence
and you can then subscribe to it
and within minutes you can apply it to
your firewall or to even hundreds of firewalls
that you may have access that you may have monitoring
required for
so the ease of use,
the product led experience is
a very big highlight in how
US security teams or network security teams
can avail this functionality.
I want to take a few minutes to talk a little bit about
what is the Black Lotus Labs
threat intelligence and why is it different
from everyone else.
The reason it is different is because we
are powered by the network
and we can see the threat infrastructure
being stood up even before the
attack has hit your enterprise,
so. To give you a parallel
here, think about a
bad actor. Let's say I'm a bad actor. I've come into
the country with malicious intent. I've
started to lease the apartment. I've started to
contact my friends, ready to launch an
attack. On,
on this, on this on this country.
Before I launch the attack,
Lumen, because of its visibility into the
network, can see what connections
I'm making and start to
create that intelligence and form
because each of the, I know they know that I have a
bad reputation.
They know that other people I'm I'm connecting to
have bad reputations,
so a combination of this intelligence is
being used to
find those network infrastructure and
attacks much before the attacks are coming into
the network.
We operate at a very big scale. We have 2
million threats that we,
we track and block on a daily basis.
We have 200 billion plus flow sessions
and DNS queries that we are monitoring
every single day, and we execute over
150 takedowns per month.
And again,
attacks are not new. Bringing down attacks is
not new to us. We have a rich
lineage. Over the last 10 years.
You can see
named attacks that Black
Lotus Labs has prevented.
We have been working with the public sector
for the last several years, working
discreetly with them.
And with the ecosystem of threat intelligence
and security companies to block and
take down these attacks that you're seeing here, whether
it's Mirai back in 2018
to System BC REM Proxy
much, much, much more recently, we
are the specialists that bring down
network bone attacks like no one else
does.
Going back to Lumen Defender
and our credibility
in bringing
high fidelity threat intelligence to
you guys,
this is not a new space for us.
We have been protecting our own
networks
for years and we are
one of the preferred.
Vendors working with public sector
companies
um to bring down nation state
attackers at all levels for the first
time we're bringing this intelligence to
commercial
uh companies and enterprises
so um
we're extremely excited that you guys should try this
out. Again,
I want to kind of give another example to help
people understand that not all
threat intelligence is the same
because you may be saying, well, I already have threat
threat intelligence from, you know, my endpoint
security, from my firewall security,
from my email security.
Why do I need another one?
Well, there's a distinction. Not all
threat intelligence is the same.
And let me use this analogy
that one of my threat research uh
leaders shared with me.
Think of the United States and think of all
the highways in the United States,
right? All these highways are interconnected.
Lumen has
the most visibility into the most
number of highways in the. United States,
why does it matter? Because the traffic that
flows on those highways,
we can see those and because we
can see the suspicious traffic from
probably, you know, benign traffic
or potentially malicious traffic, we are able
to spotlight those and take action
on that intelligence.
So
all of this curated intelligence is being
brought to you at
sort of in the most easiest way
and again to those who are thinking about
I already have intelligence from endpoint
the endpoint intelligence is super important
it's like take another analogy it's like you know
your home security each of our
homes have sensors to protect
our homes. Think of endpoints intelligence
as that.
Can it be substituted by
Lumen defender manage rules? No,
you should not. We're not asking you to
replace because you need home
security.
You need neighborhood
aerial view of what is happening in the neighborhood.
You want us to say, well, 50
blocks, 10 blocks down the, down your home,
something has happened.
That's the kind of intelligence that
Black Lotus Labs bring in.
So don't substitute it with other forms of,
uh, of, uh, intelligence.
Compliment it.
Key takeaways
we are bringing threat intelligence
previously uniquely
available to Lumen only for Lumen's
network. It is powered by the #1
network fabric that connects
all of you enterprises here.
Global visibility for the first time
is coming to AWS
to AWS customers.
It is product led integration
so seamlessly available to you
AWS network firewall customers.
Please give it a try,
and the reason for that is provides you
actionable intelligence,
great context for your security
teams, and automatically updated
so there is no fuss, pretty hassle-free
and pretty affordable too.
Thank you. I